today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
my friends if you know me you know it
brings me no pleasure whatsoever
to tell you that we unfortunately are
seeing
exactly what i've been expecting which
is that the case spikes in coronavirus
in what i guess we're calling wave three
even though i know we never really got
past the first wave but at least we can
call it
spike number three the case spike
was inevitably going to lead to a spike
in deaths
and it's happening i i would love to
have believed it wasn't going to happen
but there was no reason to believe it
wasn't going to happen
and it's happening yesterday 1200 1225
more people died in the united states uh
of coronavirus and uh we now
are seeing the leaders in terms of
deaths uh uh
california texas florida no surprise to
some of the largest population states
also illinois ohio and kansas
this is the highest number of reported
american deaths in one day
dating all the way back to august 26th
and now even when we look at a seven day
rolling average which shows us the sort
of general
direction of the numbers a very clear
uptick in the number of deaths the total
number of deaths now
through the pandemic in the united
states 227
nearing 228 thousand now remember
this matters because we saw the trumpian
right
saying through spike number two and as
we have entered spike number three
that cases may be up but cases are up
only because of testing now when we
looked at the number we saw that that
wasn't the case
uh but they would also insist we're not
going to see deaths go up
because it's younger people getting sick
who are less likely to die
we're better at treating it it's a less
serious strain
and or various combinations of these and
other ideas well
some of it is plausible i mean it's
plausible
that the deaths won't go up as much as
they might have with this number of
cases
if they were in april or july because we
do have some treatments that have been
shown to be effective in
helping prevent death in some of the
most serious cases
it's true that at least over the summer
we were seeing sort of a push towards
younger people being the ones getting
infected because i guess
older folks were taking it more
seriously but clearly
when you have this number of new cases
you are going to see a spike in deaths
and we are now heading i mean we we
can't ignore it
we can ignore it trump has been trying
to ignore it but it would be
uh it would not be prudent to ignore
that we may be heading towards the most
difficult
phase of american life from a public
health standpoint
maybe in a hundred years in the united
states this fall
and when we talk about wave three
it is true that we've not really had a
break since wave one
but maybe spikes are the right terms
recall that we had spike number one in
mid april
to about 35 000 cases a day and then we
got
down to 20 000 cases a day and things
started to reopen
and that caused a second spike in late
mid to late july of about
75 000 cases per day and then presumably
thanks to some social distancing
guidelines being observed and then also
the fact that because it was summer
and warm in just about every part of the
country people were spending more times
outdoors
we saw cases start to decline again but
this time instead of dropping to 20 000
a day
the bottom was only about 30 000 cases a
day
and then once again now we are on the
upswing regularly seeing 60 70 000 cases
per day
they told fauci he was crazy when he
said we could see a hundred thousand
cases a day in the fall into winter and
indeed if you look at the trajectory we
may well be heading to 100 000
coronavirus cases per day
and the reality is that even will with a
lower death rate
which hopefully we would have compared
to the spring
and summer because of better knowing how
to manage
cases we could easily end up with 1500
2 000 cases a day and this is very
quickly getting very very ugly now
donald trump will tell you
given the opportunity to go back to
february january february march
he would not do anything differently
when it comes to dealing with the virus
and in fact
he said it directly on a town hall with
eric bolling just about 48 hours ago
take a look
with covid is there anything that you
think you could have done differently if
you had a mulligan or a do-over on one
aspect of the way you handled it
what would it be not much look it's all
over the world you have a lot of great
leaders there's a lot of smart people
it's all over the world it came out of
china china should have stopped it
donald trump would not have done
anything
differently now it is true
that european countries and countries in
other parts of the world
argentina for example are seeing huge
spikes as well
but we're looking at our country and
we're looking at whether donald trump's
handling has earned himself a second
term and the answer is obviously no now
one other difference between the united
states and other countries is
i know we never really got past wave one
but if we use the terms
spikes we are heading into spike number
three
the spikes we are seeing in places like
france and italy as examples
these are their second spikes so while
their second spike
much like our second spike is worse than
their first spike
we are already on spike number three and
therefore we're not even comparing
apples to oranges anymore when we
compare what's going on in other
countries
sorry we are now comparing apples to
oranges we're really comparing apples to
yak meat to be perfectly frank
because the situations are so different
and the handling has been so
different and when you look at what's
happened here when you've seen
trump and republicans ridicule those who
wear masks trump even ridiculing joe
biden
on stage in the first debate when trump
in all likelihood
had coronavirus already um we
we need a change and what is
thanksgiving going to look like in four
weeks if this spike continues to grow
it's horrifying to think about and we
have some really
we're waiting for a vaccine among other
things
and we have some really important
vaccine news which i want to talk about
next
it's weird to say there's good news
anytime
someone has died of coronavirus that it
it doesn't seem right to say that
but i don't know how else to explain
this other than to say
we received a positive piece of news
regarding a tragic coronavirus
death a coronavirus vaccine trial
participant
got coronavirus and died from
complications
the news we got is that this patient had
received the placebo
not the vaccine which from the
standpoint of vaccine development
is a good piece of news although it
doesn't make this death
any less tragic so i'll catch you up on
on what happened one of the coronavirus
vaccines being developed that seems to
be
i guess we'll call it one of the top
three sort of candidates
is the oxford vaccine being developed
and tested by astrazeneca the
pharmaceutical company
this is the trial that i told you i
don't know if it was four six seven
weeks ago that was being put on hold
because there was a serious health
incident for one of the people who
received the vaccine
this happens in vaccine trials uh and
they put the entire vaccine trial on
hold in phase three
tragically that person died of
complications from coronavirus which
they contracted
and it was a brazilian participant and
that's a horrible thing what we've now
learned is that this participant did not
have the coronavirus vaccine
they were in the placebo arm of the
vaccine trial
one of the important things that's done
in these trials is that not everybody
gets the vaccine
some people get the placebo and they
don't know it in order to compare
the effects of the vaccine versus the
placebo remembering that this is a phase
three trial so what we're
looking at is not safety phase one and
two has already dealt with safety
as as the primary thing that that is
being tested phase three is looking at
efficacy
now of course if the person who died had
received the actual vaccine
you would have two things to look at
number one what does it say about the
efficacy of the vaccine of course no
vaccine is 100 effective
but number two was the death related
to an adverse reaction to the vaccine
that would put the development of the
entire vaccine in question
in this particular case it was not the
vaccine that caused
this adverse event because the person
received the placebo
and um indeed it was a complication to
coronavirus and the reality is that in a
phase 3 trial
with 30 or 40 000 people if you follow
those folks for months by sheer odds
there are people in that group who would
die or who would have a serious health
incident in this particular case the
person actually got coronavirus they had
received the placebo and not the vaccine
now this is why we do trials there are
times when an event would happen
regardless of the vaccine
in this particular case this is an
individual who actually got
the the the virus that the vaccine
is being tested against it's very sad
from the individual standpoint
it is in a sense reassuring from the
standpoint of vaccine
safety now there's also this discussion
of
if the person had gotten the vaccine and
still got coronavirus would that mean
that it's a bad vaccine and it wouldn't
it wouldn't again when you're testing 30
to 40 000 people
vaccines are not 100 effective they are
not expected to be
you don't need them to be in order to be
effective at the
herd or larger population level but
it does again raise these issues of the
efficacy of giving placebos to people
and this is a well-established area of
medical ethics the question of at what
point
would you say the placebo is no longer
ethical
because the real vaccine or the real
treatment
is clearly so effective and
that is a well-established area of
medical ethics that is sort of beyond
the scope of of this program
um i don't have an answer specifically
in this case
uh but in general placebos start to be
questioned
when there's a standard of care already
existing that is better in this case
we're testing vaccines against nothing
the vaccine is not a treatment and thus
it's a very different
sort of situation and and then again
just as a reminder
phase three is not about safety it's
about efficacy
but yes when you give the vaccine to 30
or 40 000 people
you may get data about safety that you
didn't necessarily get in a smaller
phase two trial
all of this goes to say what uh that we
are
still in process looking at various
vaccine candidates
we still don't know how long will these
vaccines
presuming they work confer immunity
how effective will they be is it a 40
effective vaccine
is it 70 effective and then by the way
at the tail end of it we really can't
ignore
that there's a large portion of the
population in the united states
that doesn't plan to get a vaccine when
it's available that doesn't have an
interest in being vaccinated
and how that affects our ability to get
to herd immunity is both a mathematical
question a scientific question
and and really a sociocultural question
as well which we will continue
uh to to discuss let me know your
thoughts on this latest news and your
sort of outlook on the vaccine
i'm on twitter deepakman make sure you
are following me there
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but you
can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
consider yourself invited to grab a
membership at joinedpakman.com
our primary revenue source quick easy
and you get the daily bonus show
joinpacman.com is the place
this morning i was browsing the david
pakman show subreddit which now
has a uh a subscriber base
of more than 24 000 of our viewers and
listeners at davidpakman.com
reddit few interesting posts one is an
article from the associated press
pointing out that
donald trump's supreme court nominee amy
coney barrett was a trustee
at a private school with anti-gay
policies
and one of the one of the comments here
is
is spot on which is imagine if instead
of being a trustee
at a christian school with anti-gay
policies
if amy coney barrett was a trustee
at a muslim school with exactly the same
policies
what would conservatives be saying right
now i think you all know exactly what
they would be saying
it would be a dramatically different
situation also
an interesting post on the subreddit
linking to a poll about the intellectual
dark web
and the political leanings of the
intellectual dark web
and the uh discussion
was initially about oh the intellectual
dark web is mostly voting for trump
and then the poll results reversed and
it looked like the intellectual dark web
subreddit was mostly voting for joe
biden
but then it wasn't clear if this was a
fair poll or not a fair poll
i actually think this we've talked about
the intellectual dark web a lot
i don't even really think the most
interesting area of
looking at the intel intellectual dark
web relates to
do the people that choose to respond to
a poll plan to vote for donald trump or
joe biden particularly because the polls
can go so much one way or the other the
for me the most interesting thing about
the intellectual dark web
is actually examining the argument that
the dark web idea comes from
this notion that uh you can't get
the views of the members of the
intellectual dark web unless you look in
really bizarre
place you know obscure places but the
reality is
the idw does really well on youtube and
there's a lot of
new interesting metrics about that so
for me what i am interested in is
challenging the false notion that these
ideas because you don't see
you know whoever interviewed on cnn that
it means that
the idw is being suppressed i don't
think it's being suppressed any more
than than
me not being on corporate media uh as i
barely ever
am uh i am being suppressed and and
in any case the specifics of who they're
voting for
in an online poll i i don't find
particularly interesting
and then lastly elitist populist is
asking whether our caller
pedro from colombia misspelled here as
colombia like columbia university of
course it's the country colombia whether
he is a prank caller
i have to tell you i don't know the
answer i don't believe that he is
actually from the country colombia his
accent
just doesn't check out but i don't
really know i i wish i knew more about
exactly the origins of that
um but maybe maybe someday we will find
out
i truly am unsure how to introduce this
next story
um but it is one of the craziest side
stories of the 2020 campaign
donald trump's personal lawyer rudy
giuliani the guy who brought us the
hunter biden story
has been caught either and again we
don't yet know
masturbating or trying to have sex
with borat's daughter from the second
borat film by sasha baron cohen which
comes out tomorrow
now that explanation may be even more
confusing borat's daughter borat's a
character what do i mean borat's
daughter that's what makes
explaining the story very difficult
actor and comedian sasha baron cohen has
a character he does called borat sagdiev
who was the star of the first borat
movie some years ago
and in the last 6 12 months 18 months
sasha baron cohen has been
filming the sequel to that film and that
comes out tomorrow on amazon prime video
in the process of filming this movie
borat and his daughter meaning an
actress playing his daughter
invited rudy giuliani to meet for an
interview
as part of the film and again this is
sort of straddling fiction and
non-fiction
as sasha baron cohen often does in the
sense that some of the people
interviewed or featured in the film
are being pranked essentially not
realizing they're in a fiction movie
and this situation ultimately led to
a hotel room where the woman playing
borat's daughter
who rudy giuliani apparently believes is
a right-wing journalist
removes rudy giuliani's microphone at
which point rudy giuliani
leans back in the bed and puts his hand
in his pants
and and again there is debate as to
exactly what was going on
at which point sasha baron cohen runs in
and yells she's 15.
she's too old for you now the actress is
maria bacalova
she's reportedly 24 years old as far as
we know not actually a 15 year old
we first heard a rumor about this back
in july when rudy giuliani reported it
to the police
supposedly saying at the time quote this
guy comes running in wearing a crazy
wood i would say was a pink transgender
outfit it was a pink
bikini with lace underneath a
translucent mesh top it looked absurd
he had the beard bare legs and wasn't
what i would call
distractingly attractive this person
comes in yelling and screaming
and i thought this must be a scam or a
shakedown
so i reported it to the police he then
ran away that's what rudy
told the new york post back in july now
at the time rudy did not say that he did
anything inappropriate
now we are getting more of the story and
and this is of course
insanely embarrassing for rudy giuliani
we still don't have the full story
rudy during the course of this interview
reportedly also agrees to eat a bat with
maria bakalova who again is playing
borat's daughter
rudy is reportedly drinking throughout
the interview he
which he's very well known to do he's
also reportedly coughing throughout the
interview and
and this was filmed during the
coronavirus pandemic so just like every
detail is as crazy as it could be
rudy involved in this incident during a
pandemic and is
again reportedly we'll see tomorrow
coughing throughout the thing
based on the reports about this from
july there was no indication that this
was this
embarrassing and the most unbelievable
part of this
is rudy giuliani last night finally
tweeted about it
and he's fully doubling down saying it's
all fake
i mean you just have to see this is a
four tweet series the first tweet is
quote
the borat video is a complete
fabrication
i was tucking in my shirt after taking
off
the recording equipment at no time
before during or after the
interview was i ever inappropriate if
sasha baron cohen
implies otherwise he is a stone cold
liar
now i've never seen someone tuck their
shirt in
in the way that rudy giuliani is tucking
his shirt in
in the picture that we're showing the
audience i might almost find it more
believable if rudy's explanation was
no i had a bible in my pants
and i was swearing on it that's why my
hand was in my pants
but i guess this is the story rudy's
going with and when the film comes out
tomorrow i presume we'll know more
about whether this explanation is even
remotely believable now there are people
who are saying
you know this is really no big deal this
is this is the left
uh shaming rudy for trying to have
what is by all indic accounts a
consensual
sexual liaison it's a private matter the
actress was
fictionally 15. in reality it was a 24
year old woman
but for me the biggest takeaway is rudy
admits he may have worked
with a russian spy on the hunter biden
story
and rudy and everybody around him wants
us to believe
that he would never fall for a honey pot
he would never fall
for for foreign disinformation he would
never be manipulated
this situation for which rudy rudy fell
is so cartoonishly absurd
that we need to recognize when rudy and
others say listen
we're all too smart to fall for tricks
we're not gonna
fall for the hunter biden story because
russians tricked us or we were set up
that would never happen just look at
this situation and look at rudy
admitting that it's 50 50 that
that he worked with a russian spy on the
hundred biden story and we're supposed
to believe rudy has any wits about him
and it's just absolutely ridiculous and
there are some who are saying
this is the end of rudy giuliani's
career period others who are saying this
is really nothing
and once the video comes out it will be
clear that this is no big deal
let's wait and see we will see very very
soon we got a break yesterday
from manic sentence fragments and verbal
glitches
and we actually heard for about 45 solid
minutes from former president barack
obama at a rally for joe biden in
philadelphia
and um it was refreshing only in so far
as it was normal english it was normal
adult communication now you might say
rally i hope that was safe
it was very safe it was a drive-in rally
people
sat in their cars and truly you know
this is not
obama deification this is just
recognizing that we've been lacking even
the most basic ability for our president
to express himself and to think clearly
for a very long time and my audience who
joined me live for this event by the way
far larger audience for this obama event
than we've been seeing for the trump
events that we've been covering live
the audience seemed to realize that you
know you don't have to agree with
everything barack obama did you don't
have to agree with barack obama on
the way he negotiated obamacare or drone
policy or many other things
the rec the the recognition seemed to be
yesterday
that we as a country are desperate
uh in desperate need of some normality
some normalization of relationships with
our allies
returning to sanity to some degree and
barack obama not only reminding us of
that but brutally going after donald
trump
during this rally trump was triggered by
it he
started tweeting about barack obama
almost immediately
trump on his way to his own rally at the
time
tweeting a bizarre breitbart conspiracy
article about barack obama
as barack obama was speaking and we know
that donald trump is very jealous of
barack obama
envious that barack obama can speak
coherently and he should be
and i understand why let's look at a few
clips barack obama here making direct
reference in fact
to trump's retweeting of conspiracy
theories as
this speech was going on barack obama
actually uh rather donald trump
retweeted a conspiracy article about
barack obama here is obama commenting on
the conspiracies
and with joe and kamala at the helm
you're not going to have to think about
the crazy things they said every day
and that's worth a lot you're not going
to have to
argue about them every day
[Music]
it just won't be so exhausting you you
might be able to have a thanksgiving
dinner without having an argument
you'll be able to go about your lives
knowing that the president
is not going to retweet conspiracy
theories
[Music]
about secret cabals running the world or
or
that navy seals didn't actually kill bin
laden
think about that the president the
united states retweeted that
imagine what
what and then continuing on to point out
the cartoonish absurdity
of donald trump promising to protect
pre-existing conditions
while trying to get rid of obamacare
which protects pre-existing conditions
you know republicans love to say
[Music]
right before an election that they'll
protect your pre-existing conditions
now joe and i actually protected your
policies to make sure people with
pre-existing conditions could get health
insurance and have coverage
we did it through something called the
affordable care act
aka obamacare
and republicans try to repeal
or undermine it more than 60 times
and when they've been asked about they
they keep on promising we're going to
have a great replacement
they said it's coming it's been coming
in two weeks for the last 10 years
where is it where is this great plan to
replace obamacare
they've had 10 years to do it there is
no plan
they've never had one well said there uh
then barack obama
weighing in on the undisclosed chinese
bank account of donald trump
and pointing out exactly as i did
imagine
if it had been obama or hillary with
undisclosed
chinese bank accounts we know that he
continues to do business with china
because he's got a secret chinese bank
account
how is that possible how is that
possible
a secret chinese bank account listen can
you imagine if i
had a secret chinese bank account when i
was running for re-election
you think you think my you think fox
news might have been a little concerned
about that
they would have called me beijing barry
[Music]
as i've pointed out before it's actually
worse than this
if barack obama had done any of the
hundreds of scandalous things that
donald trump has done
it would have been a multi-month story
with demands for congressional
investigations which
if republicans controlled the house and
senate at the time they would have
gotten congressional investigations
about a hypothetical beijing berry
chinese bank account in this next clip
you can actually
hear the exasperation in barack obama's
voice pointing out that donald trump is
running medicaid right now
and trying to kick people off of it and
many other backwards things are going on
and our water is right now run by an
energy lobbyist
that gives polluters free reign to dump
unlimited poison into our air and water
the labor department that's supposed to
protect workers
and their rights right now it's run by a
corporate lobbyist
who's declared war on workers guts
protections
to to keep essential folks safe during a
pandemic
makes it easier for big corporations to
shortchange them on their wages
the interior department that's supposed
to protect our public lands
and wild spaces our wildlife
and our wilderness and right now that's
run by an
oil lobbyist who's determined to sell
them to the highest bidder
you've got the education department
that's supposed to give every
kid a chance and that's run by a
billionaire who guts rules designed to
protect students from getting ripped off
by for-profit colleges and stiff-arm
students looking for loan relief in the
middle of an economic collapse
i mean the person who runs medicaid
right now
is doing their best to kick people off
of medicaid
barack obama very very astutely pointing
out here
much like bernie sanders has pointed out
much like noam chomsky has pointed out
we make
incremental change for the better and
then we make another incremental change
and then another and the fact that we
don't get 100 of what we want right away
is not a good reason not to vote
it means we've got to vote and then get
some change
and then vote some more and then get
some more change
and then keep on voting until we get it
right
this is very well said this is a point
i've been making for a while now i know
that there are people who will hear that
and they will say
that's neoliberal status quo trash
and to them i would say as i've said
before give me the receipts
show me the evidence that the
accelerationist ideas
actually achieve better results than
what barack obama is talking about here
i care about reality not about ideology
and i have not found such facts so
overall
very well done i think this could
actually pay dividends tonight during
the second and final presidential debate
i expect trump will be extra furious and
likely to self-destruct as a result of
barack obama now getting involved
it's not about barack obama being
perfect it's not about barack obama
being the progressive dream
it's just a desire to return to more
normal
times when our elected officials
understood
and accepted science when our elected
officials
maintained normal relationships with
other countries and weren't a global
laughing stock
barack obama will be rallying for joe
biden on saturday in florida
very important and i do actually think
that whatever your thought is about
barack obama in analyzing the election
from an
objective standpoint i think this very
much helps joe biden remember
uh that uh george w bush was
not out there campaigning for john
mccain
uh was not was not well liked enough to
be able to do it
george w bush was certainly not out
there campaigning for
donald trump in 2016 and the fact that
uh it is so obvious
that this is an advantage to joe biden
tells us a lot about the importance of
job of barack obama being out there
doing it
we'll have more of this and clips on our
instagram page
david pakman show on instagram
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
gene guerrero who's author of
hate monger stephen miller donald trump
and the white nationalist
agenda uh great to have you on gene
great to be here so first just to start
with before we get into
really the substance if people don't
know who stephen miller
is uh if they pay attention to the
things trump says
a lot of those come from the mind of
stephen miller and sometimes from the
pen
of stephen miller but who who is this
guy how did he get involved with donald
trump
exactly you know stephen miller is not
only one of trump's top speechwriters he
is also
the immigration policy architect so he's
a senior policy advisor for trump with a
major focus on the immigration issue but
you see him shaping his rhetoric
on on pretty much everything and he is
a jewish american who comes from santa
monica california
and he got involved with the trump
campaign after working
with alabama senator jeff sessions and
and various other people in congress for
a little while
and and really becoming interested in
you know a person who who he felt was
was
not politically correct and who gave
voice to a lot of the feelings that he'd
had ever since he was a teenager
you know stephen miller from the time
that he he was a teenager in santa
monica he would go around
his his his very diverse high school
telling his mexican classmates to go
back to their countries
telling them to speak english he broke
up with a mexican friend
telling him he couldn't be friends with
someone with a latino heritage
so he was he was from a very young age
expressing these kinds of beliefs when
and when he heard trump
talking about mexicans as rapists and
criminals he got very excited and
started to contribute free labor to his
campaign in the form of talking points
in the form of
immigration policies and eventually got
hired
how does someone like stephen miller end
up
given where he was born and given i mean
you know as a jewish
latino american myself i can say that
you're jews in the united states a
very reliably left-wing group 75 80 even
85 percent supportive democratic
presidents in the past
uh i don't i'm involved in all sorts of
national jewish groups i've never met
anyone who would even consider
working for someone like jeff sessions
who even if for jewish republicans would
be
almost too far to really get involved in
how does a california guy like this
end up with these beliefs
well david i i really see it as a case
study and radicalization
um you know when he was a teenager he
was going through a very hard time his
family had lost a lot of money
related to their real estate company
they had to move from a very affluent
part of santa monica
uh to a slightly less affluent and more
diverse part
stephen miller ends up having to go to a
public high school instead of a
mostly white private high school and
you know during this time period he
meets this man named david horowitz
who is a former marxist turned
right-wing radical
who was writing things at the time about
how
the only real racism is racism
against white men that racism against
black and brown people is a figment of
your imagination
that everything that we hold dear in
society and as americans
is a result of white men things like
justice equality
uh freedom that these are all thanks to
to white
men and so these are ideas that he
introduced stephen miller to
he ended up becoming like a father
figure to stephen miller
and teaching him the weapons of the
civil rights movement as a person who
came from the left
in order to attack the civil rights
movement so he taught stephen miller how
to invert
and deflect the language of the left
casting white men
as victims of discrimination based on
their skin color
casting people of color as the real
racists or the real oppressors
um and this is language that stephen
miller used throughout his career
david horowitz got him his first jobs in
in congress
um you know first with tea party
congresswoman michelle bachmann and then
with
john chidag of arizona and finally with
jeff sessions
of alabama um but he but he introduced
him to these
really white supremacist ideas and how
to launder them
through the language of heritage and the
language of national security
and the language of economics in order
to make these ideas palatable
to the mainstream which is what stephen
miller has been doing
in the speeches of donald trump um over
the course of his his time working for
him
this question might apply more generally
than just to stephen miller but
there's this incredible irony of someone
who is part of a group
that was not considered white by
the white european oppressors for so
long right
jews were the whole much anti-semitic
discrimination is based on the
jews are not white jumping in full bore
to repeat the talking points that were
essentially
used against jews that that and that's
really
probably a broader phenomenon that we
see among some on the right
exactly you know he takes ideas directly
from white nationalist and white
supremacist literature this has been
documented you know emails i've reviewed
of his
strategy papers that he's worked on and
these are
groups that not only vilify and and
promote
violence against people of color but
they feel the same way
about the jewish people and it's a it's
a real conflict that exists inside of
stephen miller
most of his family is appalled at what
he's been doing in the white house
as far as the rhetoric and the policies
which largely
target immigrants who are fleeing
persecution and violence in their home
countries
you know stephen miller's grandmother on
his mother's side ruth
she spent her retirement um compiling
the family history
so that stephen miller and her other
grandchildren would never forget
the value of people who come to this
country in nothing but the clothes on
their back and speaking no english which
is how stephen miller's
great grandparents came here from
eastern europe fleeing
a persecution fleeing nationalist
agitators
um in eastern europe and and she also
recorded for him
the lessons of of you know the dangers
of demonization
and these are lessons that that most
people in the jewish community
you know value and understand how
important they are but their lessons
with stephen miller from the time that
he
he was young has been not only ignoring
but but directly
attacking and it's worth noting that his
mentor david horowitz is also
you know a jewish man and and he you
know
he's he he's sort of his entryway into
white nationalist
uh ideologies which which he would you
know he he constantly says he's not a
white nationalist he's not a racist but
if you look at his
his writings they're very much um
echoing these white nationalist talking
points
um but he but anyway he he he starts out
with this very anti-palestine
anti-arab anti-muslim mentality
um and eventually you know stephen
miller broadens that out to include
um all all immigrants but this is why
you saw one of the first actions that he
took in the white house
was the muslim ban um and and then
eventually you know
the systematic separation of of migrant
children from their parents and
the systematic dismantling of the asylum
system at the u.s mexico border
and and the destruction of the refugee
admissions
system as it exists in the united states
most of these policies
have impacted people seeking legal
pathways into this country
because they are desperate because you
know they're facing death threats at
home
this is not about criminals and cartels
crossing the border sneaking across the
border
illegally stephen miller's policies
disproportionately impact
families who are trying to do things the
legal way
yeah this is not ms-13 as donald trump
often likes to talk about at rallies
well and that's something that stephen
miller inserts into trump's speeches he
knows that ms-13
he is like this you know thing this
symbol that he can use to rally people
around policies that harm
families overall um but yeah i mean
the reason that these policies work this
way is because he's pulling them
directly from
think tanks created by a man named john
tanton a eugenicist
who believed in population control for
non-white people
a white supremacist who believed in the
genetic superiority of whites
and these think tanks like the
federation for american immigration
reform
you know they they they seem innocuous
they have very banal
sounding intellectual names but they
exist
to to read to find ways to
dismantle uh legal pathways into this
country for people from latin america
and africa so to zoom out a little bit
very often when the topic of of the
trump administration and trump's
rhetoric and white nationalism comes up
you will hear these sort of reflexive
defenses about
trump's son-in-law is jewish and his uh
you know daughter converted his
grandkids are jewish and that type of
thing when i
interviewed white nationalist richard
spencer years ago
during the trump administration he said
that
he doesn't expect trump to actually come
out and say
things exactly the way he says them
but that he sees trump as sort of like
the closest thing to his ideology
although more recently spencer himself
has said they're kind of done with trump
and okay fine we can move past that
but mike my question more broadly is
what are the ways
in which donald trump's language may be
even unknown to trump because it's being
inserted by miller it doesn't matter
what are the ways in which trump has
sort of signaled to these groups that at
least to some degree he's their guy
well to start with a more recent example
i mean trump
for his relevant strategy has been
really working to conflate
anti-racist protesters and black lives
matter protesters with
quote agitators and anarchists and mobs
who want to destroy this country
that language of agitators and
anarchists referring to anti-racist
protesters
comes directly from a book called the
camp of the saints
which stephen miller promoted through
breitbart in 2015
and which is about the destruction of
the white world by brown
people described as monsters and beasts
and teeming ants toiling for the white
man's comfort
and that this book explicitly endorses
hatred and violence against people of
color as a
survival mechanism so it promotes the
conspiracy theory of white genocide
that has motivated so many acts of white
supremacist terrorism
including the el paso massacre that we
saw last august where 23
people were killed by a man who thought
he was saving the united states from a
hispanic invasion um so so
so his language is is really dog
whistling if you can even call it i
don't
think it's even necessarily dog
whistling i think it's directly echoing
with the white genocide theory
are there other examples in terms of
trump's specific lines i mean early
there was
you know looking at the origins of
america first and it sounds relatively
benign and
uh you know how could something just so
so so uh
uh simple uh have the this horrible
origin uh so so to speak
are there other examples you think are
the relevant ones to think about
yes so so what a very common recruiting
tactic in white supremacist circles is
to use
to highlight um you know examples of
alleged crimes committed by people of
color and this is something that trump
has been doing from the
very earliest stages of the campaign and
and he started out with this sort of
more instinctual emotional racism saying
that mexicans were
were criminals and rapists but when
stephen miller joined
he he started to really use very graphic
gory descriptions of alleged migrant
crimes that really works to incite white
fear and white hatred
an example being you know referring to
migrants
slashing people with machetes or
crushing a woman's eye sockets with a
hammer
um you know butchering little girls
language that is extremely violent and
is and is meant
to to provoke you know real sense of
fear that is something that comes from
stephen miller
also the use of false migrant crime
statistics saying that
you know thousands of americans have
been murdered by
by elite quote illegal immigrants this
is
this is false you know immigrants rather
they come to this country
legally or illegally are actually less
likely to commit crimes
than uh citizens but is but trump
constantly uses false statistics about
immigrants and this is stephen miller
pulling from the white supremacist
recruiting tactics that he's familiar
uh websites like american renaissance uh
which he has been
um you know inspired by for for several
years and which uses this tactic of
highlighting migrant crimes and pumping
out false and misleading
uh crimes attacks crime statistics about
migrants as well as black people
uh the book is fascinating it's called
hate monger stephen miller donald trump
and the white nationalist
agenda we've been speaking with the
book's author gene guerrero
uh so great to talk to you and i really
appreciate your time and and the the
book is excellent
thank you so much david the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we talked about this a little bit
yesterday but i want to dig into it more
because the story is growing donald
trump is threatening and now promising
to potentially humiliate himself by
releasing his upcoming 60 minutes
interview early and he seems to be
sort of like a runaway train that at
this point nobody can get under control
yesterday i explained that donald trump
on tuesday filmed a 60 minutes interview
for
for this sunday he was interviewed by
correspondent leslie stahl
we learned moments after it all happened
that donald trump
ended the interview early he abruptly
left and he didn't come back
and then he almost immediately tweeted a
six-second video of leslie stahl at the
white house without her mask on which is
really weird behavior for a president uh
who's supposed to be an adult
well then trump threatened to release
the 60 minutes interview before it would
air on 60 minutes as if it would be some
kind of punishment to them tweeting
quote
i am pleased to inform you that for the
sake of accuracy and reporting i am
considering posting my interview with
leslie stahl of 60 minutes
prior to air time this will be done so
that everybody can get a glimpse of what
a fake and biased interview is all about
everyone should compare this terrible
electoral intrusion
with the recent interviews of sleepy joe
biden now it didn't make any sense then
it still doesn't
but since then it's gotten even funnier
with donald trump tweeting
pictures of himself sitting for the
interview
i guess meant to make him look strong
but then hilariously he tweeted out
pictures of his press secretary
kaylee mcinanni handing leslie stahl
a book of donald trump's accomplishments
on health care
and it's one of these obvious props it's
like a gigantic oversized book with
thousands of pages
but when you zoom in on the pages they
look like they're blank like it's it's
not even just a prop in theory where
it's just filled with like executive
orders and random stuff
it actually seems to be merely a prop
with blank pages of no
uh of with no content whatsoever
and trump thinks that that makes him
look good enough that he's tweeting it
out
and drawing attention to it well it's
even worse than that
bess levin wrote a great article in
vanity fair
which explains that donald trump spent
the entire afternoon on tuesday
after the interview brainstorming a with
aids
how to go after leslie stahl it's not
exactly clear what he came up with
but by wednesday morning donald trump's
chief of staff mark meadows was on fox
business network
complaining about leslie stahl take a
look at this
well he didn't walk out i mean the
characterization of that
he spent over 45 minutes with leslie
stahl i've looked at every single minute
of the interview and then some
we have tape of of every single minute
listen when you have a 60 minutes
reporter they should be a reporter not
an opinion
journalist and and she came across more
like an opinion journalist than a real
reporter
journalism should have standards and
we we need to get to the bottom of it so
i think the american people will be able
to see it
sort of strange to hear a trump
administration official
talking about standards not being
adhered
to but donald trump really may be on the
verge of a self-humiliation here he
again today talked about
how he is planning to release i guess
they must have their own recording of
the interview
to prove something and by the time you
even listen to this clip or watch this
clip it's theoretically possible that
trump may have already done that now on
the back end of this
some of the people who saw the interview
who have spoken to vanity fair
said you know the truth is the interview
is not that bad it's not like it's
the interview it's it's okay it's not
great because it's trump but
it's at least not worse than the things
donald trump has been saying daily
at his rallies so this may be another
one of these instances where donald
trump
is calling attention to something that
would not have been as big of a deal if
trump had let it go
but this has been a theme of the
presidency self-inflicted damage
a huge part of the entire russia fiasco
was trump's self-inflicted damage
through tweeting
and other unnecessary things and you
could even
i mean i i don't know but even what led
to trump's impeachment which was the
ukraine fiasco
some aspects relate to optional
things trump said and things trump
tweeted and things that donald trump did
which at least circumstantially might
not have created an environment in which
donald trump ends up getting impeached
maybe not maybe so but the point is
the self-inflicted damage is
never-ending
truly never-ending with this guy and
that's another aspect of you know the
the final debate is tonight and for
those who
hear this after the debate you'll
already know the outcome of course
but between the barack obama joe biden
rally yesterday
during which trump started tweeting
conspiracy theories about barack obama
from breitbart
um with the 60-minute stuff that's going
on
with donald trump's recent sort of i
don't i don't know if i want to call it
desperation
he's not despondent but he seems to at
least in the back of his mind recognize
that there is a chance that he gets
completely embarrassed in 12 days or
however long we have left until the
election
it seems to me that trump is on a hair
trigger to completely self-destruct and
as you know
tonight during four of the 15-minute
section during four minutes from each
15-minute section of debate
um candidates will be muted while their
opponent gets their two minutes to speak
uninterrupted
i would not be shocked if trump just
can't control himself
and tries to shout over the muting and
gets picked up by joe biden's microphone
or by moderator kristen walker's
microphone
anything could happen tonight i invite
you to join me tonight we will be live
about 30 to 45 minutes
before the start of the debate on
youtube twitch and facebook uh the
debate is at 9 00 pm
eastern i will start 30 to 45 minutes
before that
really sad news from yesterday uh we
lost a really special person that
i know some in the audience know about
but a lot of people probably don't and
i'm talking about the great james randy
james randy is a guy who started his
career as a magician
but he really became known for debunking
and quite frankly embarrassing all sorts
of
woo-woo pseudo-science psychics
homeopathy all sorts of other different
scams and james randy and the james
randy educational foundation
were known for sponsoring a prize
which offered a million dollars to
eligible applicants who could actually
demonstrate evidence of any paranormal
supernatural occult power
psychic power or any of it under agreed
upon
test conditions nobody has ever
successfully claimed the available
million dollars
but there have been some really
hilarious things that have happened to
people who
tried you all know i'm fascinated by
scams
and pseudoscience james randy who passed
away
uh this week at the age of 92 was one of
the truly great debunkers of this
nonsense if you spend some time on
youtube
as i have looking at james randy videos
you will immediately notice how astute
this guy was there's an amazing video
this is decades old where a supposed
i don't know if this guy's a psychic or
a telekinetic or what
this guy claims to be able to turn the
pages of a phone book with his mental
powers
and james randy immediately identifies
that what the guy is doing is
surreptitiously blowing on the pages
he kind of like does a weird thing with
his hands to make it look like he's
using his hands to turn pages
but james randy can tell the guy is
blowing on the pages phone book pages
are very very thin
so randy brings out these packing
peanuts that are super light
and all of a sudden the guy can't do it
anymore and starts claiming that the
the fluorescent lights might be
interfering with the energy or something
it's an unbelievable thing to see james
randy was also a big debunker of
homeopathy which as you know has no
active ingredients
um and there's an amazing video i don't
remember if it's a ted talk or something
similar
where at the beginning of james randy
speaking
he is casually eating dozens of little
what look like little candies or little
tablets and then later in his
presentation
he mentions by the way at the start i
ate an entire bottle of homeopathic
sleeping pills or herbal sleeping pills
of some kind i don't remember exactly
what they were
and based on what the box says i
shouldn't even be able to be awake
speaking to you right now because i had
the entire box
and of course he's fine because it does
nothing
just a really clever smart guy hilarious
as well
he explains how psychics do cold reading
he's debunked the formerly very
prominent pseudoscience guy
yuri geller he has videos on youtube
explaining how supposed psychic
surgeries are done
how the spoon and fork bending tricks
are done just really many other things
and an advocate for science and
empiricism and rationality
so a sad day james randy dead at age
92 check out his youtube videos
fascinating guy
a real fighter against scams and
pseudoscience
which so many people fall for not just
ideologically
but pour money into believing in some of
this stuff
check him out i don't think you will be
disappointed we've got a great bonus
show for you today i hope you will join
me we are going to talk about
speaking of falling for scams half of
trump supporters believe
baseless sex trafficking q anon claims
very sad for what it means for the
country we will talk about a supreme
court
food stamp ruling that is important we
will talk about
steve wins republican donations i have
some personal steve wynn
stories that i will tell on the bonus
show get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist dot com slash
david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video